last week first person shooter evolved
went free on PC and received a major
bump in its player base I'm Lucy and
welcome to your poor be one gamespot
news update publisher 2k and developer
Turtle Rock Studios have announced that
evolved stage 2 has seen 1,000,000 new
players since its release on PC less
than a week ago the announcement was
made on evolves official Twitter account
and to celebrate players can claim
Griffin's blood eagle hunter skin for
free all you have to do is log in to
evolve stage 2 between now and July
eighteenth at ten a.m. PT the skin will
become available after the event ends on
July eighteenth according to steam
charts the monster hunting game went
from a June peak player count on Steam
of 234 people to 50 1099 in the last 30
days this surpasses the game's peak at
its februari 2015 launch which was
twenty 7403 turtle rock is also said it
will bring evolve stage 2 to consoles
eventually the reason it's not on
consoles at the moment is because of the
long certification process that each
update is required to go through on
consoles Turtle Rock wants to bring all
of the fixes it makes on PC to consoles
at once making the process much smoother
for players the ship to going free
brought multiple tweaks and changes to
evolve overall performance and low times
have been improved and the hunter
classes have been reworked to make it so
teams are less reliant on experience
trappers and medics you can see more of
the changes over on gamespot com so have
you picked up evolved since it's gone
free to play let me know in the comments
below or come by me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games for more on evolve make
sure you head over to gamespot com
you